all right in order for me to channel
adele
i sort of have to think like a black
lady in london right
we knew nicki minaj could do a solid
british accent oh my god what should i
say um let me think but we had no idea
she could do a perfect adele
on thursdays the late late show the
rapper chats with james corden and he
reminds her of this iconic carpool
karaoke moment adele
nailing nikki's challenging verse on the
song monster
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
and that's when corden flips the script
and asks nikki to give us her best adele
because the thing is
normally everybody knows i told my
british accent is sort of like a a posh
white lady a rich white lady right yeah
we're speechless this impression is a
10. well adele i sort of have to like
transform like like maybe she used to be
like hustling like nickels and dimes in
the hood and then and then you know like
she got her big break because that's
that's what i see when i see her like
she's always like it's so expressive
right
yes it makes sense the anaconda rapper
can deliver a flawless adele after all
she told et and 2019 that she was
itching to collaborate is there an adele
nikki something could be in the works
would you do it if she asked
yes and yes yes and yes
but adele made me swear to secrecy that
i'm not allowed to tell anyone that i'm
working with her and we already shot a
video and it's an epic song okay
speaking of music the rapper also tells
james fans can expect a new album the
question is when
well
i it i do know it soon and i do know
it's a lot sooner than it's ever been
right um and i know that it's coming
this year ooh
and i know and i know that it'll be out
before the summer time i'm very excited
about that to hold the barbs over we've
been blessed with nikki's latest track
do we have a problem with little baby
in the dramatic nearly 10 minute long
video we not only get nikki the rapper
but also nikki the actress and honestly
i'm not in the mood to play with you are
you even
have the information you claim you have
or we're done
and when the rapper isn't busy
entertaining she's spending quality time
with her family excuse me
the super bass rapper and her hubby
kenneth petty recently took their
one-year-old son to the lakers vs
clippers game and judging by nicki's
courtside instagram videos the fam had a
blast
[Music]
you